first Diana show Caesar how excited Maya
gets when it's time to get the leash for
a walk hey that's very dangerous okay
the touch is just to let her know that
I'm I'm serious about what I'm
projecting a minute he kind of tapped
her at the back she immediately stopped
it's like wow how did he get that kind
of response uh quickly you have to clean
the area so when you come in here mm-hmm
you have to be able to come in as you
own already before you even got here the
reason why she came down is because
somebody owned the place and jumping was
not allowed that's really what we did
but I they said sit down because I don't
want you to hurt her
you followed me I come with that type of
conversation I will accomplish exactly
what you did with just a jumping dog I'm
kind of surprised that she's sitting
well like this well surprise well I'm
glad that you're surprised well this is
like her area in a way she's gonna like
yeah but I I'm owning the place
well yeah can you move your legs is that
possible that you can reach her like
this there we go like that has perfect
perfect really perfect that simple that
simple touch what'd you just say is give
me space please but we got the whole
conversation you just made it happen I
just always thought like using your foot
may be abusive what are you that's true
yeah you're using her technique okay did
you turn on you you using internet
lifter we think this that's right good I
get in you now it's amazing
stay there hold it okay stay there
no stay today stay there you're not
being mean you're just being the pack
leader I just an area that you don't
touch often right as it is it's like
becoming clear and it's clear it's hard
though cuz she's so cute alright that's
fun
humans take a little longer my tendency
was to move away from her because it
fear that she's gonna hurt me
Dannan showed me when you step in she
doesn't like that she moves back there
and then she would sit very obediently I
tried that a few times it was amazing
she try it again right it took it
took you what are you doing you're going
like that well it's just what am I'm
doing I'm not and I and you keep turning
around look at me right yes I keep
saying that energy oh you're not gonna
look around but if I mm-hmm so if I move
and then I send more energy to you can
we feel it that's right yeah
you